today and how it's changing they'll be
through politics sport business
entertainment public life or there'll be
everyday people caught up in the events
of our times i'll be putting my
questions to tonight's special guests
[Music]
good evening the world watches with
horror as the war in ukraine consumes
victim after victim what will putin do
next
there are still attempts at negotiations
the un secretary general arriving in
ukraine but against the thunder of the
guns with more towns devastated and
increasing allegations of mass killings
diplomacy feels rather pointless what's
going to happen i talk to someone who
knows more than most fiona hill wants a
working class girl from county durham
then the top russia expert at the white
house she advised three presidents till
it came to an unhappy end with donald
trump
also on the show schools are now back
and at last this spring sees the return
of real exams but the long legacy of
lockdown still has many of our
youngsters in its grip
can those two years ever be recovered
and can education avoid being dragged
into the bitter divides of culture wars
i'll talk to ofsted's chief inspector
amanda spielman
plus the world came together in glasgow
last year to tackle climate change how
distance that now feels i talked to one
of africa's most eminent states women
grasa michelle formerly fast lady in
south africa and mozambique who tells me
she thinks this generation of world
leaders are failing us
so let's go straight to our first guest
fiona hill now a senior fellow at the
brookings institution and an expert on
russia she was an adviser to three men
who held the most powerful office in the
world but as a woman from the north of
england she came up against challenges
and has a remarkable insight into how
one president donald trump dealt with
world leaders and women in power
fiona thanks so much for coming on the
show i've been looking forward to
meeting you so i'm really glad you're
here and i wanted to kick off with where
you came from let's start with who you
are
um you're a working class girl from the
northeast and you ended up advising
three presidents on foreign policy
to those who don't know you can you join
the dots in a way that makes sense to
people about where you started and where
you got to
yeah look um it was very much the
product of um
time and place um as you mentioned uh
working class but i grew up in the north
of england in county durham small town
bishop auckland at a time when basically
the bottom had totally fallen out of the
local economy
it was born in 1965
um at that time the local coal mines are
closing down my dad had been a coal
miner the only job he'd been able to
find when all the mines had closed down
was in the local hospital and the
national health service and uh bishop
parks as a porter you know beginning on
really the lowest of the economic ranger
and having to sort of reinvent himself
and when i was leaving school in 1984
not only were all the mines it was all
you know british nationalised industry
british rail british coal british steel
british shipbuilding the national health
service i mean pretty much everybody i
knew worked in the nationalized sectors
and not in the private sector
unemployment in the town was really high
but unemployment for youth across the
entire country was very high only 90 um
dollars to say 90 of kids leaving school
in 1984 didn't immediately have
something to go on to
i was very lucky i was in that five or
six percent of kids who have the ability
to go to college or polytechnic
university
you know doing my a levels and the local
education authority in this case county
durham because of the basis of means
testing and if i'd done well enough
would pay for me the chance to go to
college and my dad basically said to me
at the time look pet you know there's
nothing for you here yeah if you get a
chance to go to
university and you get a chance to
education that he hadn't got he left
school at 14 you've got to take it but
really
the the reason i was able to take that
opportunity was because my local
education authority paid for all the
fees and a maintenance grant for me to
go to university and that kind of
ability to do that now has really
reduced i mean it was again time and
place placed my dad pushing me out to go
somewhere else and to do something else
because there wasn't any jobs in bishop
auckland at the time but the ability
because of local
education authority educational grants
and then i was able after that to get a
scholarship to go to harvard university
in 1989 again because of money not that
was given by the government but that
money here that had been endowed to
harvard university by you know a
benefactor it was actually frank knox
the former secretary for the us for the
navy in world war ii would give him
money for the british commonwealth and i
got that grant to go to harvard so all
the way along the reason i'm where i am
today is because there was a grant to
subsidy a fellowship in a scholarship uh
some kind of assistance i mean i i
couldn't have done this on my own
without that now you uh
went on to advise three u.s presidents
you are an expert on russia you have uh
written a book on putin you've obviously
just written another book
donald trump
you advised donald trump um
when did you realize it wasn't going to
work out between you
and donald trump was it sudden or was it
this gradual realization that i'm not
going to be able to do business with
this guy he's just not it was right from
the very beginning i mean when people
say you advised trump i didn't advise
him on anything in fact very few people
did because he didn't really listen to
advice and he just wasn't particularly
interested and he had a kind of a vision
of who should be an advisor anywhere and
it certainly wasn't you know kind of a
middle-aged woman with a funny accent
and right from the very beginning it was
basically who were you what could you
possibly know about you know any of this
were there any sort of women you'd think
he would take advice from or was it just
anti-women no it wasn't anti-women i
mean there were women that he um trusted
and worked with for a long time and
somebody like you know people be
familiar with kellyanne conway do you
think he had quite a bit of respect for
her his own daughter ivanka trump i mean
the times when he clearly listened to
her you know there were there were
others who were in his orbit you know we
hear about hope hicks you know for
example who was one of his assistants so
it wasn't just that was just you know
that trust
and you know who they were you know i've
actually saw him interact with people
like angela merkel chancellor of germany
and listening to her but she explained a
lot of things to him in various meetings
he took her seriously because he was a
chancellor of germany it was kind of who
you were and how you were related to him
seriously because i remember watching
how he treated her because i saw
prescott and i i thought he
was not always respectful to her
no look i think you know this is a bit
of a bizarre thing
um to say she would have been better off
if she spoke another language other than
english trump you know responds to
people i was going to use publishing as
an example right he had to listen to him
people go oh my god he was always
talking to putin for great length
because he hit to be translated
and so part of the whole power of people
like putin or even you know angela
merkel you know if she's decided to
speak in german was that trump had to
actually listen because he didn't know
the language and he couldn't interrupt
them and he couldn't kind of hone in on
something they said because he had to
hear them out where was with theresa may
i mean he immediately could just
interrupt her and you know he often did
that with other people as well if they
had an accent i mean you know for
example macron of france if he spoke in
english rather than in french and you
know he was stumbling for a word or he
didn't use quite the right word trump
would hone in and immediately interrupt
them
okay because that was kind of his style
and also if your voice was of a higher
register as theresa may's could be i
mean i'm
cognizant of that myself i mean i don't
speak in a particularly low register
trump would immediately see that as a
kind of sign of weakness
and it was also people's electoral
status so after theresa may for example
called the snap election and her
majority was reduced he saw that as
weakness it was kind of a reflection of
his own fears of you know having a
reduced majority and how that made
people think about you his epitome of
the strong powerful leader was a guy who
spoke in a big deep voice
and who you know kind of basically in
his view then come under detention did
you ever did you ever see him interrupt
with theresa may i did and many other
people as well i had the whole of europe
in my portfolio not just uh russians
didn't make you angry did you find her
angry when you thought she was the prime
minister of the united states very
irritating because he did that with
other people as well i mean as i said he
would interrupt people he would jump in
on them um he wouldn't you know listen
to them you know with respect there was
not just that mutual respect with people
and about you i read in an interview
actually i also read it it's in your
book
uh that you said that his
you were referred to by his chief of
staff
as i hope you don't mind me repeating
this as the russia [ __ ] yeah i learned
that after the fact actually it was a
journalist who was um writing a kind of
a profile of me uh for one of the
american magazines and who interviewed a
lot of people around that and he said
did you know they called you that and i
was like no but i wasn't particularly
surprised this wasn't you know across
the board this was the kind of coterie
of people around around trump his chief
of staff yeah and it was basically who
does she think she is you know she
thinks she knows all of this stuff do
you know all that stuff but it's not
it's not repudiation i mean look you
know as a woman i mean you and i and
many women in public life and many women
not in public life have to basically put
up with that kind of dismissiveness well
actually now you've said it i i wanted
to ask you about something i hate you
across it because obviously you live in
the u.s but um
there has been an issue today and i
think we've got the newspaper article
where by angela rayna who is the
deputy
labour leader
has had a rather
well very misogynistic article directed
there you can see it there stay in the
crows tori's accused rainer of basic
instinct ploy to distract boris so you
can see andrew rayner there and they're
liking it to sharon stone there in in
basic incident liking in her to the
deputy leader of the labour party
there's a quote in that piece
uh of angie raynier where this is a an
anonymous conservative mp saying she
knows she can't compete with boris's
oxford union debate in training but she
has other skills which he lacks angie
left school at 16
from a working class background had a
baby is now an extremely successful
politician
what what do you think about
that about
that quote about that article i think
it's just a classic misogynistic put
down i mean quite recently after i've
been speaking out you know donald trump
said about me she'd be nothing without
that accent which of course is ironic
because in a uk context you know the
accent
marks me as being working class from the
north of england would get other kinds
of comments you know in the uk you know
obviously one view of an accident in the
us another but it's just that kind of
put down like you just said about the
russia [ __ ] when people
feel intimidated by women in powerful
positions which is clearly the case with
angela rainer i'm not wanting to be
offensive to read the daily mail but you
know that always you know i'm not
surprised that there's this kind of
commentary that people don't check
themselves when they're writing you know
these kinds of things
and absolutely just what you said it's
indicative of the problem that women
have over and over again in public life
doesn't matter what kind of background
that they have but especially people
from the working class i'm also told by
people oh well look you know there's
lots of people like you who've risen up
in the time you know since you have
that's just not true
and you know i mean show me the number
of working-class women you know with a
northern accent or any kind of accent
that would mark them there who are in
public life and then case in point
angela rayne as you said really a
remarkable unbelievably remarkable
career and personal trajectory they said
leaving school after 16 having to raise
you know a child on her own i mean i i
saw on that picture she's not wearing
anything different from maya i mean what
are women supposed to wear what what are
we you know telling people and there's
an element you know in my book that i
talk about right from the very beginning
when i had to give evidence an
impeachment trial
the first thing
that i was told was we'll have to figure
out what you're going to wear and i was
like not what i'm going to say i mean
preparation if i'm gonna answer the
questions but about what you're gonna
wear so you're not distracting yeah so
that people won't look at you and say oh
god look at that woman
i know that feeling um
just before i want to get on to russia
and ukraine because you're an expert and
i really want i've got so many questions
to ask you one thing about trump the
impeachment child you became a national
uh figure you are now very well known in
the us and you were
highly praised for how you handled that
testimony that you had to give but in
the book two you write
about how a lot of friends and
associates had warned you against
working at the wise house under trump
do you regret not heeding those warnings
was it a mistake to go and try to work
for him no i don't think it was a
mistake at all because i did it in the
spirit of public service
you know patriotism for the united
states at a time when the russians had
putin had messed around in u.s politics
and it created an absolute chaos on the
domestic front that we're still dealing
with now
and you know i'd written a whole book
with a colleague about putin i'd been in
the national intelligence council so
i've been intel on the list it wasn't
that i didn't know what putin was up to
i think where i should have been more
careful
when i went in because i did pay
attention to what they said and i took
it very seriously i wanted to make sure
i didn't get you know kind of embroiled
in the domestic politics was really
doing my homework about some of the
other people who were there
because i knew more about the kremlin
and also dirty politics and i really did
about how this political machine was
working around trump this personal
culture the personalization of
everything
on our trip to india last week with the
prime minister he said he became the
first g7 leader to explicitly say he
thinks putin will win this war could win
this war
he's right isn't he he he is going to
win but you you would say he has to me
any cost what does that look like well
it doesn't look good for him either i
mean you know when we say win define a
win right there's a public victory in
other words when you know things are
devastating result of it and we could
very easily see putin himself prevailing
by still being in office in the same way
that bashar al-assad has done it in
syria complete devastation in the
country but he's still there that is
exactly but putin that would be a win it
wouldn't be a win for anybody else by
their definition and not for the russian
people either or for russian oligarchs
or for you know kind of the russian
military that would not be a win but for
putin it will be because he has
prevailed and his act of will has been
borne out and yes he um has uh
devastated the russian economy but in
his view we'll already have devastated
ukraine and shown us who's the boss you
understand his mind probably better than
a lot of people what does it look what's
the on the ground
result for him that makes him claim
victory or allows him to claim victory
or gives him an off ramp right so he can
end the war yeah he wants us to take an
off ramp and ukrainians to sue for
surrender so but ending the war would be
declaring victory and it might look
something along the lines of what he
said to george w bush in 2008
which is you know george ukraine isn't a
real country part of it is in eastern
europe and part of it was given to us or
part of it belongs to us
and you can just imagine him being in
possession of the whole of the donbass
daniettes
the rubble of mario paul and all the
cities around the sea of azov all the
northern parts of crimea linking all of
that uh together crimea to eastern
ukraine having odessa and the other
fabled black sea ports of ukraine in
jeopardy as well and ukraine effectively
cut off from the black sea and
dismembered and that looks like a win to
putin how does it end for him i mean i
interviewed chris still the other day
and he said he didn't see a way back
like he
that he can't
lead russia after this all ends in a way
i mean what how does it end for putin a
palace coup he died i mean how
he prevails and he just grinds it out
over another decade with russia
the pariah of the world or the west at
least yeah all of those things because
you know i mentioned bashar al-assad and
siri we said assad should be gone in
what was it 2012 10 years on he's still
there
robert mugabe we kind of felt there's no
way that he could keep on going in
zimbabwe so much you know push back
against him he just goes and dies in his
position we still got nicholas maduro in
venezuela we've got you know that we had
the castros one after another in cuba
you know every time people said oh
surely this must be the end i mean i
think it's exactly that it could be a
combination of all of those things and
but it also could be
you know there could be a change i mean
we've often been caught out before right
nobody expected gorbachev to come along
and even under medvedev when putin
stepped back and put dimitri medvedev
into the presidency for a while there
was a bit of a change of pace as well as
a change of face
you know we don't have crystal balls
something unexpected can always happen
but you don't think that there is an
internal
there's a eternal rebellion against him
that there aren't people around him that
will think this has gone too far you
don't think there's an internal coup
scenario really it's possible we saw
that with gorbachev right when gorbachev
was pushing through you know kind of
reforms and there was a push back by
hardliners it's entirely possible that
but again i can't say in what kind of
time frame that pressure builds up
because of massive losses in the
military there's a backlash to get from
soldiers mothers and their families
that you know people around start to
put blame where it's due which is on
putin and the tiny coterie of people
who've made this decision and say look
we've got to stop this but we can't
necessarily stop it with him there if
you were advising uh president biden now
what would you advise him to do in terms
of the short term into the medium term
well the short term we've got on the
medium to around the long term we've got
to stay unified as the west pushing back
we've also got to
extend the diplomatic front because one
of the things that we're really worried
about is putin and a nuclear weapon i
mean you haven't asked that but it's
something about zooms yeah always and
that's unacceptable what he's doing
threatening to you know basically if you
don't back off and give me ukraine i'm
going to blow you all up or i'm going to
you know set off a demonstration
tactical nuclear weapon there we should
be out there with every other nuclear
power the uk of course is a nuclear
power france is a nuclear power china's
nuclear power but so india and pakistan
everywhere else and say look what he's
doing so diplomacy on that front
sticking together to blunt the um
russian military operation and being
dedicated and committed over the long
term over changes in presidents
political parties you know we have to
find mechanisms for this to help ukraine
get back on its feet but not stepping up
military intervention
those things are all part of this we've
all we're already in there um in terms
of all of the support that we've been
giving ukraine but we have to be careful
because putin wants it to be about the
us and the western nato he wants us to
kind of basically be in there because
he's telling the rest of the world
including india and everywhere else
where you've just been this is nothing
for you here this is nothing for you to
pay attention to
this is just a fight with us on the west
and nato and ukraine is collateral
damage a lot of countries and their
leadership believe that we have to push
back against that that's a short order
um goal for us to persuade the india's
indonesia's malaysia's you know and
others um and um asia
africa and elsewhere that look what's
happening to ukraine is something you
should all be concerned about as well
and fiona they keep telling me i've got
stocks i've run over yeah
i i could go on and on i believe it's
fascinating
as a child you said you were scared of
nuclear war and here we are again a
major nuclear power openly threatening
using those weapons are you scared
actually not in the way that i was when
i was a kid i was scared of the unknown
because i didn't know how this was all
play out i mean now i've got some pretty
good ideas of how this all plays out and
the whole point of this is we shouldn't
be scared and intimidated
for putin right now this is a game even
though it's a pretty dangerous one
nonetheless because he's scared he's
scared of being usurped he's scared that
he doesn't have sufficient conventional
power he's scared that we could indeed
push him back he's scared that ukraine
could win so this is basically the act
of a scared person himself he doesn't
say he is because he has to portray this
strength and power but he's falling back
on his new nuclear weapons system so we
have to understand
where he's coming from and we have to
push back against that so the whole
secret of this is don't be scared and
intimidated but take some action
one more question they'll tell me off
if you could you say to me confidently
though here now that you don't think he
would use a nuclear weapon or you simply
don't know i don't know and i think he's
thinking about how we could use it you
know as a demonstration effect in a way
he's already used it because he's
talking about it and we saw what he did
in chernobyl in terms of sending the
military right through the chernobyl
exclusion zone shelling the zaparisian
nuclear plant he's already in that space
and you know threatening you know moving
nukes here and there and using iskandar
missiles and talking about it that we
know can be you know basically nuclear
armed he's already in that space so we
have to push back we have to work with
others this is the point where we say to
the rest of the world look you really
want to be in a world with a nuclear
free-for-all that's why we have to put
putin and his you know nuclear
missiles back in the strategic bottle
here you know he's basically unleashed
the nuclear genie we have to put that
back fiona hill thank you so much uh we
need to go thank you so much cameron now
because i've got loads more questions
thank you thanks for coming on thank you
it's great great to be here with you
beth thank you for having me i loved it
thank you thank you
fiona hill there well stay with us
because coming up next after a grueling
two years for our country's schools we
speak to the chief inspector of schools
ofsted's amanda spielman
[Music]
a lot of action going on i'm alex
crawford and i'm skye's special
correspondent based in istanbul
this is what makes the job
so fantastic
i'm stuart ramsey and i'm sky's chief
correspondent
well there's a real sense now that
people are beginning to expect that this
whole airlift is coming to an end and
they're really really desperate
we saw snatch squads going in grabbing
people and putting them into trucks
[Music]
you either live and recover
or you die
[Music]
okay so that's like a wall that's the
war yeah
help you understand the world with us
over the past 24 hours the soldiers have
been attacked on a number of occasions
[Music]
it's really sending a clear message that
venezuela is eager for change
[Music]
to take you to the heart of stories that
shape our world
they were convinced the united stand
[Music]
the enormous explosion it's just come
down i think the monsters just landed in
between us
the information on this could bring down
the entire network not just in iraq and
syria but across the world
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
withdrawn it's so so hot
[Music]
i love my job because
i get to do something that is
contributing to a better future
[Music]
[Music]
we support communities to grow food in
lost and unloved spaces across the city
so our main kind of driving force is to
get people growing
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back england's chief inspector
of schools has announced a bold
five-year plan she promises more
inspections more research more
intervention in event intervention to
help schools and child care get over the
trauma of lockdown but the mood in the
staff rooms and at the school gates is
fractious can amanda spillman convince
teachers and parents she's the person to
safeguard the interests of children and
she's with me now in the studio amanda
thanks so much for coming in
i wanted to start with
covid and where we are now at school in
schools as a country we've been
encouraged to move past the pandemic to
get people back to work back to normal
do you believe there will be long-term
consequences in the state school system
because of covid around the pandemic
and also the lack of funding sufficient
funding for kids to catch up i do think
there will be consequences
at one level we're back to normal
schools aren't operating with
covert restrictions lockdowns bubbles
all the rest of it but it's been an
incredibly tough couple of years
um heads teachers are weary they've been
working so hard and a great many
children have really struggled it's been
very very tough for them so while
everybody's back in school
there's a lot to catch up on and it's
really hard work with really tired
people so absolutely there's a lot of
effects still to come through and amanda
your job obviously is to inspect schools
and look at standards sir kevin collins
who you'll know he was briefly the prime
minister's education czar
back in the moment when the government
was talking about schools and recovery
he asked for 15 billion pounds to help
put funding into schools to help kids in
state schools catch up
and in the end the government i think
offered up about three billion in
additional funding when he stood down he
said i do not believe it will be
possible to deliver a successful
recovery without significantly greater
support than the government has to date
indicated it intends to provide
do you agree with him
i'd like to wind a step back and talk
about the ways in which covid has
affected children
we've got some children who are really
catching up um pretty well in the normal
classroom with their normal teachers
making accelerated progress
that's quite a large proportion actually
so i don't think we should be too
pessimistic overall but of course we've
got some
who for all sorts of reasons are a lot
further behind and structured
intervention um to help them is really
important a great deal of that
comes from the school's own staff in
fact one of the things we've seen about
tutoring about all the tutoring that
schools are putting place with the
national tutoring program is they've
actually got a strong preference for
using their their own staff
over staff supplied from other sources
so actually it's interesting that
schools want to work with their own
resource if they possibly can
and i think a great deal of good of
really good tutoring and catch-up
interventions is being organized that
way
so i'm not as pessimistic as some
um what we are we are working on this
we're going to haven't had a point do
you think kevin collins
but there was also a question because
one of the things that's transpired is
it's actually been quite difficult to
find enough tutors and to find the right
tutors who can tie in so if there had
been a huge amount of extra money in
school budgets i'm not sure that we
would have had extra tutors to spend it
all on
so the most important thing is to do it
really really well and have it very
tightly integrated with what happened
amanda let me put it another way because
we're also seeing and you'll know this
the gap between state school funding and
private school funding almost double
this
investment money going into school fees
for private schools funding per pupil
dropping in real terms in england as
head of offstead are you concerned by
this growing inequality
between education
it seems that there's been an arms race
in the private sector for years right
somebody builds a theater somebody else
has to build an even grander sports
pitch the facilities race
um in the private sector has been quite
extraordinary i think a lot of that's
been about attracting people from
overseas i don't think it bears any
relationship to what happens in the
state system here or or anywhere else
come to that and i also don't think it's
necessarily has a great deal to do with
the education i don't think it you don't
think it it entrenches inequality
between those children that can go to a
private school and those children that
can't it does entrench some undesirable
kinds of equality but if we look across
the world
state systems everywhere in developed
countries are operating with quite
similar amounts of funding english
schools are very much in the normal
range so the first job is to make sure
we use what we've got really well and
think in a very structured way about
curriculum and teaching and make sure
that children have have the the very
best experience well look well we
believe we can make we make fantastic
schools okay well let's come on to your
strategy you put out a five-year
strategy this week to try and address
the devastating impact on the pandemic
with a big focus on the early years
flagging the children
lagging there are children lagging in
communication and languages schools some
of the pretty skills some of the the
preschool kids
is that your your biggest area of
concern when you look across the piece
of early years to secondary education
we've got concerns right through
we've done a particularly large amount
of work on school age and
post post-16 over the last five years um
in the light of covid we've seen
particular harm for the youngest
children and remember children who have
just turned two say have lived all their
lives in a pandemic they've seen adults
around them with face masks they've seen
far fewer people than usual it's not
surprising that for so many of them
their language and communication
development are well behind where they
would normally be that their social
skills are less developed so getting
them
back on track has got to be a really big
priority and that's that's why we've put
it right in the center of our new
strategy and as i understand it the
cabinet talked about this week
looking at
cutting child care costs because of the
cost of living crisis by loot diluting
the ratio of adults to kids
in early years education you know that
you know you can one adult at the moment
i think has three children
would you worry about that in the
context of what you're talking about
that actually they need more input is
that a concern to you
i think it's really important um to look
to look look comparatively here i've
seen oecd analysis
that says we've got the most generous
staffing ratios in the developed world
for early education of course there's a
trade-off between between staffing and
cost it's very important that we protect
the quality of education and the quality
of care for children but but but i do
think it's right to look and make to
look to look at it to make to make sure
that we're not gold plating that we're
making right that that we've got early
education um as affordable as it can be
as well as
quite really high quality so in
principle you're not opposed to the
loosening of those ratios in principle i
don't think ratios of themselves drive
quality we should look at quality
quality of education quality of care and
safeguarding first and foremost okay
one other thing i wanted to
ask you about in relation to
uh children's education is something
that the government's social mobility
commissioner said yesterday she told a
group of mps that girls shy away from
studying physics because they don't like
hard maths what was your
response to that what do you think of
that i think it was a terribly
unfortunate thing for her to say
um it really was um there is an
imbalance between girls and boys it's a
rather large imbalance by the time you
get to post 16 study of subjects like
physics and further maths
um i think but i turn it around and say
actually it's telling in some ways it's
telling us something about girls
strengths
so many girls get to age 16 say and find
that they're all rounders that they're
equally good at everything
and really struggle to decide what not
to pursue because at that age we do we
do make young people choose boys by
contrast are much more likely
to be much better at maths and science
than they are at language based subjects
so it's much more likely for them to be
a no-brainer to stick with the maths and
science route
and at one level of course we don't want
to to march children off and say even if
you don't want to do history
to do maths you want to do history
you're not going to do history
but we should be concerned when
disproportionately
girls shut them out shut themselves out
of some of the most interesting some of
the most lucrative and some of the most
socially valuable parts and it's the
technologies scientists who are solving
climate change a bit of a foolish thing
to say really then given
the efforts to get girls into stem
subjects there's some fantastic efforts
in hand and of course we must balance
the rights of individuals um with wider
social aims but yes a very unfortunate
thing to say
um
let's get on to to you briefly i've got
i've got lots of other things to ask you
about but
amanda you are not a teacher by
background and anyone who's a teacher
who lives with the teacher my mum was a
teacher so i remember this the shadow of
fear cast by an ofsted inspection she
was a head teacher and believe me it was
a painful period in our house when there
was an ofsted inspection but but with
previous inspectors chris woodhead or
michael wilshaw they were fellow
teachers and you aren't you were someone
that was from the city trained and
worked in the city has that been a
barrier for you with teachers
do you think that sometimes they think
you don't understand the pressures
they're under because you haven't walked
in their shoes i'm sure that happens
sometimes but i think what people lose
sight of
is that it was actually only until my
late 30s that i worked in the city and
then i changed career and i've worked in
education
um since
for the last 20 years um so i did a
masters in education and then
i became part of the founding team at
what's now one of the biggest academy
chains so i have lived and breathed
education from the point of view of
somebody
running an academy chain um really
getting into the problems of the most
disadvantaged schools um the cha the
chain i worked for um was particularly
targeted at children with the
the steepest path to climb we were
taking on the toughest schools
working out what curriculum what
teaching were needed
working out what it would take to to
turn those schools around and i was
doing that for years before i came into
this job so i have seen
all the things that can go wrong with
the school and all the things that can
go right with the school a very close
quarters and been working intimately
with the people who are directly
responsible in those schools
and amanda coming on to um working in
schools and some of the
the cultural issues around schools
in the u.s there's been a situation
where schools and curricula is becoming
a battleground a political battleground
do you fear that happening here you
recently said that schools have to tread
a careful path between being damned for
being intolerant or slammed for being
woke what do you mean by that
this country fortunately is is not
polarized at the level of that i think
we're seeing in the united united states
but nevertheless there is some very very
hot political contests and of course
many of those um things that children
become that children become aware about
and so of course it's right that schools
talk about politics talk about current
and topical issues but there's an
important requirement on schools which
is to be politically impartial and
that's that's small p political it's not
about um
um political political um whether they
talk about conservative or labor or lib
dems it's in the broader sense they've
got to make sure that they give children
as a balanced diet overall and that they
don't teach
um think contested ideas as fact or
doctrine and you think they're doing
that or they're in danger of doing that
in
in the main most
most schools walk this line really well
but it's very hard at the moment because
there are some very passionate voices
and when something is presented as a
sort of moral issue rather than a
political issue it can become hard for
people who are really engaged in in
something that for them is very much a
moral issue to recognize where it's
something
um
what's a good what's a good example
um we did an inspection recently of an
independent school
which had
um a curriculum which was
very much about social justice
and which we did find didn't meet the
political political political
impartiality expectations but the
teachers there very much saw it as
that that the moral um value of teaching
this curriculum overrode
political impartiality they found it
hard to see that
let me go on to something something else
about gender and schools is it important
that schools maintain single sex
provision for girls using toilets and
changing rooms for example in your view
this is one of the toughest ones for
schools at the moment and it is coming
up more and more and more and we're
hearing about this although it hasn't
come up from inspection much yet we know
it's getting to be a bigger issue in
schools
adolescence is a time when
everybody's exploring sexuality um
increasingly gender all other all kinds
of other aspects of of um
their identity
and schools have to stay on top of that
so they do have to handle children with
gender identity issues sensitively but
um safeguarding children and biological
sex absolutely is and continues to be
relevant right the way through so you
think it does matter to have
single sex provision for girls each
school every school has to work out its
own arrangements but it's important to
recognize that we've got so conflicting
rights here this is not something that
you can steamroll and we have to
acknowledge
um that some of the gender issues come
directly into conflict with some of the
sex bases amanda would your message be
to schools uh
that have removed single sex spaces
what's your message and that they
shouldn't
my message is that is that they've got
to make sure that the jet that the very
real tensions here have been air
discussed that they've got buy-in for
whatever solution this is we don't
prescribe what school what schools do
when conflicts between rights arise this
is not the first time that we found
ourselves um in a place where we can see
a clear conflict of rights so so much of
my time at ofsted we've been dealing
with places where religious rights and
sex sex rights conflict and we found
illegal segregation
or where religion and sexuality can flip
whereas religious schools don't want to
teach about homosexuality
i've got one quick question for you on
the issue of single sex schools over 50
percent of teachers in england have said
they have at least one pupil who's
identified as transgender do you still
think single sex schools will exist in a
generation's time or will society have
moved on from that form of demarcation
between people
there are certainly far fewer single-sex
schools than there once were but
in a world where parent choice matters
i'd be very reluctant
to see a mandate
that there should be no no single sex
schools yes issues of gender identity um
create some difficulties at the
borderline no question about that um but
i certainly wouldn't be calling to to
abolish them all right well amanda
we've run out of time thank you that was
fascinating
well stay with us because coming up next
in a moment we'll speak to the former
first lady of south africa and
mozambique grass and michelle as the
world looks to the future of tackling
climate change
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it can be tempting at times of darkness
to seek advice from earlier generations
of world leaders gracia michelle is a
veteran advocate for global peace
women's rights and humanitarian justice
she was also at various times wife of
nelson mandela and wife of samora
michelle the president of mozambique now
as a deputy chair of the elders she
works alongside figures such as jimmy
carter mary robinson and ban ki-moon
first up thank you so much uh for taking
some time to talk to us at sky news
today i i just wanted to reflect with
you a bit on where we are in the world
there was a time i think when everything
felt positive at the turn of the century
your late husband nelson mandela was
free dictatorships were in retreat the
un millennium goals were about tackling
poverty and now i look around the world
and we have war in ukraine ethiopia
yemen and elsewhere humanitarian crises
authoritarian regimes global warning is
accelerating
from your point of view grasa where did
it all go so wrong
we have to recognize that
most of the
crises
we are faced with today
are man-made
so
i believe it's mostly
failure of leadership
if i want to give an example
the
climate change issue
or
how many years we have been told
year after year
with unequivocal
statistics showing exactly how the
situation is getting out of control but
the leaders of the world they don't seem
to be listening they don't seem to be
taking the with the same magnitude of
the crisis
measures which would be
tackling and preventing the situation
where we are today going back to africa
there was optimism
about africa about development but
there's still conflict there's still
positive poverty
massive unfilled human potential why is
it taking so long again does it for you
go back to leadership not just
leadership within african nations but
also global leadership from other
leaders around the world is it back to
that again
definitely
because uh
why for instance a country like ethiopia
would be involved with itself
there's no other answer it's because
leaders are failing to
one
to develop governments which will
involve everyone in the specific
countries to be in charge
second
they fail i mean to be inclusive
bringing
regions bringing different ages bringing
different skills to be part of the
decision making in their own countries
and of course
terrorism will use all the gaps which
exist i mean to flourish
so it is not doubt it is no doubt an
issue of leadership
but you are asking about the world as
well and the climate change is a good
example of
failure globally
how many times since copenhagen
the leaders of the world they pledged to
give a hundred billion dollars every
year to tackle climate change but
particularly for mitigation adaptation
and supporting poor countries i mean who
did not make the climate change i mean
reach the levels in which we are and
they promise and promise every year and
nothing happens so you find failure of
leadership
within
africa yes but on climate change it's
mostly global because africa is paying
the price of a situation it did not
create
and
i believe we need we need to encourage
our young people and women i will insist
on women as well because they are most
imp impacted on this i mean to
take leadership to voice
what are the aspirations and to mobilize
so that we have
different kind of leadership which is
going to take into account the feelings
the aspirations the visions which are
coming from people themselves
and gras just finally there's been some
coverage recently about the commonwealth
uh with prince william saying um that he
won't necessarily head the commonwealth
he might not be head of the commonwealth
do you think an organization like the
commonwealth still has
any resonance uh with africans and
african nations
i think uh
any
kind of organization
which build the bridges
amongst peoples of the world amongst the
nations it's welcome
what i believe the
commonwealth should
do is
to perhaps to
revisit
the reasons
why these nations
across the globe are coming together
not to be based on the past yes
but it to be based on
interest
of these nations
as part of the human family today and
tomorrow
so
yes it is relevant but i think it needs
to reinvent itself to readjust to what
are the issues which would bring these
nations together congress i love the
idea of
building bridges between nations and
that the commonwealth can stand for that
like it can be nations with common
interests working together on issues
such as climate change but i guess the
question is do you think that the royal
family
of the united kingdom should head that
group of nations
well i i will leave
i will leave it to nations who are
part of the commonwealth to to to decide
that because i don't think it's a
personal opinion is my but
have you seen what has happened recently
in the caribbean
and do you follow what is it
what is the message which is coming from
thee and i think it's not against the
royal funds it is mostly readjustment
of the kind of relationship in which
it's a relationship amongst the equals
within an organization
and
that is what i'm trying to say in my own
words of how
an organization can adjust
the
itself
the the the uk
is
is a country which yes in the past had
a certain kind of a role in dwell but
the uk today
has to recognize that democratic
institutions are the ones which are
prevailing
and
how
does this happen i'm just suggesting
listen to what the caribbeans are saying
okay
grasa it was an absolute pleasure to
talk to you thank you so much
and i love those roses on your jacket
they look absolutely gorgeous um thank
you so much for your time it was an
absolute honour to talk to you thank you
the wonderful grass and michelle there
well thank you to all our guests this
evening don't forget to download the
beth rigby interviews podcast for more
content coming up next the news at 10.
[Music]
[Music]
i love my job because i get to do
something that is contributing to a
better future
[Music]
[Music]
we support communities to grow food in
lost and unloved spaces across the city
so our main kind of driving force is to
get people growing
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
it's 10 o'clock this is sky news at 10
our top story scott sibley becomes the
first britain to be killed in ukraine a
second is missing
the mayor of mariupol tells me nato must
act now to stop the russian bombardment
of his city
[Music]
and if our allies join in with this war
sooner the sooner we will stop the war
which is now destroying our houses
killing our residents our ukrainians
and president biden pledges 33 billion
dollars to help ukraine resist vladimir
putin
also on the program tonight a drug
addict mother sentenced to